hey jacksepticeye I bet you think we're
bros just cuz we hang out I bet you
think we're straight-up
home dogs just cuz we hugged once well
guess what I hate my dog and I hate you
too this is the jacksepticeye roast
prepare to get flamed [ __ ]
[Music]
jacksepticeye more like Jack septic fly
hey Jack when I first saw you I dragged
Jack your facial hair makes you look
like a prepubescent member of Isis and
don't even think making fun of my hair
because you wish you had this hair [ __ ]
that was so unnecessary
your abs looks like a vagina so I have
to blur it blur that [ __ ]
point proven hey Jack this is what your
friends think you look like but this is
what you really look like which is
convenient because your videos are about
as cringy as a dub commercial hey hey
Jack I found I found your twin get it
guess you're Irish see this
[Music]
jacksepticeye is clearly not see don't
hate me i only spit the truth jack
you make me want to loose my clothes and
not because you're hot because you're
ripping me off
[Applause]
how come I can't find any diapers in
your merch store I like to start selling
some PewDiePie dildos here so your fans
can act like you and suck my dick you
only made it big because I gave you a
shout-out
you might make a wish big this is you as
a [ __ ] Minecraft all you do is
[ __ ] screaming your [ __ ] videos do
you think you're funny and creative
people say I'm the Trump of YouTube yeah
well then you're the Hillary Clinton's
the only reason people watch your videos
is because you're a train wreck and
people can't look away
you're literally worse than
raywilliamjohnson I'm sorry that was
that was too far jacksepticeye more like
Jack septic tank
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm roasting your whole family Jack
you're all a bunch of potatoes let's fry
[ __ ] you got roasted now what are you
gonna do buddy [ __ ] some people like to
think that Jack got big because of me
because I gave him a shout-out but I
gave a [ __ ] ton it I'm gay like third at
least 30 people a shout-out and none of
them went nearly as far and we're nearly
as successful as Jack that's because
jack is a talented funny charismatic
beautiful Irish man I love you
I'm happy you're my friend please don't
unsubscribe I hope you guys enjoyed this
roast
let me know if you want more leave a
like if you enjoyed and I'll see you
Bros in the next video as always stay
awesome bros ok we will go with evan
s-s-san sf5 ponds cuz he needs to wake
up and kill himself why are you so much